bak
bir Üniversitesi Tıp Fakültesi çocuk
sağlığı ve hastalıkları anabilim dalı
Öğretim olsun
hakkımız ettiğim yaşamak ilk benim
yediğim ilk günden itibaren
olan bu en kritik en fazla nedir bu
önemli uygulamak için kullanılan vücut
ülkemizin bildiğin kavramını kullanarak
anlatmaya ve bu dönemde etkileyen
faktörleri sunmaya çalışacağım
biliyorsunuz ülkelerin gelişmişlik
düzeyi Aslında bebeklerin hızlarıyla ne
kadar az uyuyorsa çocuklar 12 o kadar
gelişmiş demektir
140000000 bebek KPSS her yıl doğan
bebeklerin ilk baktığımız zaman ilk
dönemlerde
o ilk beşiğine baktığımız zamanda daha
çok ilk iki yaşta 10'dan fazla ilk bir
ayda içinde yap Ne günler çok önemli
yaşama Bu ilk dönemlerde tutulmaya
baktığımız zaman ülkelerin gelişmişlik
burdaki bizim ülkemizde görüyorsunuz
yaklaşık olarak bebeklerin
ilk yılda 1.900 kaydediliyor bizim
ülkemizde bin 945 65 yaş içerisinde
kaybetmiyor şimdi bu dönem yaşama
tutulmakta bu kadar önemli olan bugün
gelişmeye baktığımız zaman niye
baktığımız zaman gerek yok musun gerek
gerek Baş çevresi olsun Bu da mı gelen
küçük olduğunu
bir inceleri
bu En çok bu dönemde bir Gelişmekte
olduğu zaman bir bebek olduğu zaman
fazla bir şey olduğunu bu kaybolmaktan
bağlantı çok önemli bir şeyler arasında
da çok bu dönemde olmakta ve
artıkk yaşına geldiğimiz zaman iyi
gelişiminin yüzde sekseni
tamamlanmaktadır ve 1 nolu üç katına
çıkmak bunu bu takip ettiğimiz
bebeklerde
gelişme baktığımız zaman konuşma olsun
bir gelişim olsun çok yeni Şimdi bunu
görüyoruz yani bakın ilk iki yıl en
önemli en kritik
Peki o zaman bu ikili koyduğumuz zaman
ama yaşamın başladığı
ilk günden itibaren 19.ay eklediğimiz
zaman
işte bu
bütün yaşamını etkileyen
bu dönemle ilgili olarak acaba
bu
okullar dışındaki genetik faktörler
dışında ne istiyor
acaba çevresine olarak bunu etkileniyor
mu bu günden itibaren bir program varmı
acaba ilgili olarak asla 1960 yılında
yapılan
hayvan bebeği
ilk işaretlerini bir çalışmaydı bu
çalışmada erken dönemde beslenme
istiyorum soruları daha sonra azabı da
verilmesinin bile onun vücut yapısı bu
çubukları değiştirmiştir sınav daha kötü
sonuçlara gittiği ilgili olarak 19 75
yılında yapılan çalışmada Bu ilk olarak
erken dönemde ki bu sektörlerin yeni
dönemi yaşamı üzerinde önemli etkileri
olduğunu gösteren bu çalışma izin alacak
Bu çok
çalışmadan Yıllar Sonra 1009 16 yılında
yayınlanan çalışmada varken içimde Biz
Sizlere düşününce üzüldüm
kalp hastalıklarının çok olduğu bir
coğrafyada vardı Onların doğumuna
baktığın zaman onların
birçoğu o zaman bir çocukları öldüm
insanların da düşük doğum ağırlıklı
olduğunu diye ilişki olabileceği yeni
1935'de ki çalışma gibi düşünerek
bir bir satılıyor bir patatestir
bir
anne karnındaki gelişimi duyarlı olduğu
bir dönemde ki Uygurların alıcı ve uzun
dönemde etkileri ulaştı ve bunu da artık
bir programa zeka sürecinin denir ifade
etmiş ya da kısaca biz erken dönemde
bulamama diyebilir yani bebeğin yapısını
sadece saklıyorlar bizim özledim
Ya anne karnında ilk rahme düştüğü andan
itibaren çok faktörler
mesela hormonları edeceğim
işlem süresi dolduğu zaman saldırmadan
korkacağım olumsuz etki göstermeye
gelirse neden oluyor o da gene olumsuz
ettiğim
Selam
Gebelik döneminde Annenin kendi ihtiyacı
var ama onun üzerine en az alması
gereken bir 42 Zaman akıp gelişmiş
ülkelerde 92019 ama işe geri kalmış
ülkelerde oturamadım senin için almak
çok olumsuz sonuçlara neden olur ise
düşük protein alındığı zaman bu
Çocukların
okul dudak Annem gebelik önce kilosu az
ise kan basıncında artış koroner kalp
hastalığı fazla oluyor
Yüksek bir yağlı diyetle beslenme
Işıtmak abi o zaman da kardiyovasküler
hastalıklara neden oluyor
Sadece
bir gösterelim takibi onlar da yeterli
miktarda alınmadığı zaman yine ileride
ama sal yapılarak olduğu için alınmaması
da yine olumsuzluklara neden olur Bakın
silah
küçük kilonun altında Hindistan'da
yapılan bir çalışmada olabiliriz 15
oranında görülen kalp hastalık
ameliyatı olursa çok daha düşük oranda
geliyor aynı şekilde ip Erdoğan son gene
de mavi azaldıkça ederdi daha fazla
oluyor Yine biliyorsunuz daha çok kilolu
olanlarda görmeniz için direnci de seni
bu
oldukça farklı olarak pazarlık vardır
şimdi biz ne kadar geldik bu ilk dönemi
konuştuk bundan sonra Bebek doğduktan
sonra 6 ay sonuna kadar yani bugün bu
bir yarışma doğru yaklaştığımız olduktan
sonra bu yolculuk güzel
ve bu anne sütü her canlı için
kendilerine sıkıldı ilk aşısıdır ilk al
kaydırın Silahsız Hidayet iki yaşına
kadar annesinin verilmesi bu
suvs 36 nerenin toplanır ederseniz 5-6
ölümlerden bahsettiğimiz içine
emzirmeyle anlama gelir ileri yaşamak
etkisi sadece o zaman değil annesi alan
çocuk hasta olur ve şeker hastası oldu
daha az olur daha zor kanser gelişir
orta kulak iltihabı olur
Eğer
bir yapılan bir çalışmada gideceğim
çalışmada bakın anne sütü aldıkça
azalıyorsa aypisi
zekası daha yüksek sana sahip oluyor iyi
beslenmeye ilişkin olarak zeka ile
ilgili yapılan bir çalışma yani özet hiç
bir günde ki kötü dersin kısa dönemde
beyin gelişiminin bozulmasıyla
sen sonra azalmasına bozuklukları neden
olarak işletmeci sallama konuşmalarına
yapılabilir kendimi olarak bugün şeker
hastalığı diğer diyabet hipertansiyon
gibi hastalıkların daha fazla olmasına
neden olur
şimdi bu hani şimdiye kadar çok beslenme
ilişkisi konuşacağız artık sonrası
bulutları daha çok güzel
hayatımıza giren
zıplar Bu nedir şimdi
bunun dışında bakın cep telefonu benim
cep telefonu için yapılan çalışma bakın
2017'deki zamanı anlatmaya gece içine
konuşup Ortaokulu olsun
o telefonu ne yapıyor cep
telefonunuzu çakal ve değişti Mahallesi
dalgaları var
ne kadar küçük olursa akacak değişti Bu
bir olarak söylüyor inceleyin şoklarda
fazla bakın ilişkilerdeki işler beşlik
misin Dolayısıyla mobil telefon ne
yapıyor her gün okula kalkabilirsin
oluşur Bunlar Yok ya gidiyor bu dönem
hasarları Hadi cep telefonu
kullananlarda yüzdür bulamıyorlar
düşecektim
bunun sonucunda ne oldu bu
da gelişini ha fazla
iyi misin
Hadi kötü ilişkisi olduğunu
söyleyebilirsiniz olmadığını söylüyor
ben bakayım mesela değilsin ile ilgili
20 yaşlarında 42 göster yirmi yaşından
sonra iki kapanması Bu benim söylediğim
bunların Gelişmekte olan böyle için daha
fazla olduğunu gösterir aldı dakika
üzerinde Bu
kulak köpeğin içi
Neyi bozuyor bu haberdar olabilirsiniz
izlediğiniz içimde kayboldum zaten
Peki çevre kirliliği
konuşacağımız birbirine çevre kirliliği
ile ilgili çalışmaları Zeki Amerika'da
oldu orada istasyonlar bizim içimizde
var bir
hafifledi gibi yerlerdeki gebeliklere
bakıyor bakalım için ki ortamda ise 18
19 atıştan sonra orada bunun için erken
olduğunu
bunu ya da uzun oldu
ne yapıyor bir çalışmada babası bu erken
doğduğu Işık olmazınız en hızlı olmadan
da açıldı
ıcepark yine bakılarak yapılan çalışma
çok yeni bir çalışma 2100 bu
çevre kirliliği her yıl dünya çapında
altın ya ne kadar yakın olduğu için
yolda düşük kilolu bebek Sen budur
olan şeyler sorumluluğunuz gerektiğine
dikkat ettiniz
Eskiden 4 ilmek de vardı Hiç bir tane
yabancı madde olduğu yerlere sigara
Bugün dünyadaki en önemlisi
davranışlardan bir tanesi
ülkemizde bakın her yıl her yeni doğan
bebekten şimdi anne karnındayken
sigarayla kalmış
geçici bırakalım bu ne oldu bir şey ne
dedim
buradaki nikotin dünyanın en güçlü damar
bulucu maddesi Dolayısıyla damarsal
beslenen bebeğin anne karnındaki bebeğin
beslenmesini bozarak erken bu işi
doğmamış olmasını yazan olur anne
karnındayken sonra hareketlerinde
olumsuz etkiliyor ve
işte böyle daha fazla oluyor Sadece içen
değil Herkes basit olarak göstereceğim
aynı zamanda onun yanındaki siyah
dediğimizde uzaklaştıran
hareketleri aramız ederim olarak solunum
yolu enfeksiyonlarını ı orta kulak
memesi gibi erkek solar ismi
36 bebek sendromu satın Şevket bazen
biliyorsunuz bu yirmi beşinden sigara
sorumlu anne sütünü daha zaman sadece
sigara içilmesi astım Annem
açılardan da bahsetmeyelim olmaz
açılarda çok önemli aşılandığı için
hiçbir geçici hukuk
hoşlanmadığı için 2 milyon de değil bunu
söylüyorum herp açısı bu hastalığa
karşılanmadığında bir insan hakları
olduğu İnsan Hakları Beyannamesi bugün
yapılmış işte değil
o kadar önemli ki
toplantılar kongreler düzenlenmiştir
sağlıklı bir gebelik
sağlıklı Bebek sağlıklı bebek ve sağlık
Son olarak şunu söylemek istedim Hayatın
en önemli dönemi ilgilidir
iyi günde kötü beslenme ile yaşamı
olumsuz
bu telefonu bu telefon çevre kirliliği
ve sigara buraya 2'den de bir
var ve yaşamı tehdit eden toparlar bu
İnşallah çocuklarımla
daha bilinçli bir şekilde
çocuklara bakımı ki çocuklar
uzaklaştırabilirsiniz sigara gibi cep
telefonu gibi içerden bakalım hepinize
sağlıklı bir ya da gelecek diyerekten
kalamaz
[Alkış]
abone ol